this was not previously on wand division
it was previously on infinity war
i'm way too lazy to go back and check if
they've actually shown this in any
previous episodes but even if they have
you're still breaking the 1978
previously on accords
set in motion when the show alice
petitioned and was denied yusuf and
alice doesn't live here anymore clip
because scorsese didn't consider it
cinema
also i was going to stop sinning how
long these previously on segments
continue to be but then you had to go
and title this entire episode previously
on
which means this is essentially 40 full
minutes of previously on and how did you
ever think you'd get away with it
in case you confused it with the famous
witch trials of salem oregon yet you
have betrayed your coven
and we will all now take our hoods down
dramatically and simultaneously for
maximum creepiness
i did not break your rules they simply
bent to my power
the new england patriots are they
killing her taking away her powers
giving her indigestion you don't know
when the show isn't interested in
telling you either but those pretty blue
lights sure are cool huh
now she's purpling they're blue and it's
sucking the life out of them because
purple please
i can be good no you cannot parents
[Music]
kids she does look shocked to meet the
real us doesn't she
oh good we're back to the current day i
was beginning to fear this episode would
be a never-ending parade of flashbacks
with no real story momentum
glad that will never happen that's
adorable
my thoughts are not available to you
jets they never ever were
then how would wanda not know that
before now and yes i thought about the
fact that agatha could have been
supplying wanda with false thoughts but
then i also decided that if i keep
filling in the blanks for this stuff i'm
doing marvel's job for them despite the
rumors they don't pay me for this
that accent really comes and goes
doesn't it considering the show has
already played around with this joke
hackathon would be excellent but
repetitive at tv sins
i was so patient
waiting for you to reveal your true
self pretending you have great patience
because you waited a few days for the
next episode i mean
new information netflix has ruined us
all also wanda's version of patience is
apparently resurrecting a dead brother
and killing a dog in an attempt to force
wanda to reveal her powers
i got close with fake pietro fiatro if
you will we'll handle the lazy nicknames
around here agatha snarkness
but you're so crippled by your own
self-doubt that you believed it
look i'm sure there are more pietro
reveals coming but the idea that agatha
would use a completely different person
to
imitate wanda's brother on the off
chance that she's so distraught that she
wants to believe it it's quite
the stretch sure it's fun for us but i
can think of at least five different
ways snooper could have snooped without
relying on that long shot
of course there's transmutation show
decides to pause for a few minutes to
give us agatha's witchcraft and forced
exposition master class
magic on autopilot disney's corporate
slogan for its film division
accidentally makes it into the script
but it's time to look at some real
reruns
in the end agatha was always going to
have to do the ghost of christmas pass
routine right
so why did she wait agatha might enjoy
getting to play in wanda's dick van dyke
and bewitched playground but once it got
to the full house her family dies i feel
like agatha should have made her move
and if you're calling pietro a move go
back a few sins and see how we felt
about that
going with the colorized i love lucy set
geez irina maybe step away from the
window you've got the [ __ ] purge
going on two stories down
this might be a better time to take
shelter instead of immersing your world
with dick van dyke
thick van dyke again always sitcom
sitcom sitcom
insta also what else could have been
picked everything in the suitcase was a
sitcom
here's a sim for disney plus not
releasing their own shows on physical
media now how am i supposed to watch
people watching dvd on dvd on dvd
also this episode is a straight classic
but it's not the one wanda picked wanda
said she wanted to watch episode 21 from
the second season which is my husband is
a check grabber it may look like a
walnut is episode 20.
the tv dvd dvd player both power chords
and the av connecting chord survive this
where'd you get the big guns wanda
puberty
don't be scared you already lifted once
you said bored wrong
and we're focusing on an infinity stone
again i swear they should have just
called them the herpes stones because
this
is never going away do we have to see
wanda watching sitcoms in every scenario
from the past
the show sets that aspect up well with
the suitcase full of dvds and the tv
night with world war three happening
outside the maximoff residence
unless of course this hospital uses the
brady bunch as punishment of some kind
which makes sense because that show is
torture also this seems like exactly the
kind of room that wouldn't have
anything included but a cold slab table
but would also have taken the time to
integrate a color television with access
to the brady bunch
priorities if we're accessing wanda's
memories from these scenes then how are
we seeing this
these moments would have been completely
outside of wanda's vision broken pieces
of view are adding up buttercup
are they though or are they being
retrofitted this must be that new math
thing i've heard so much about
[Music]
breaking dad i've never experienced loss
because
i've never had a loved one to lose
but what is grief if not love
persevering damn it marvel just as soon
as i'm ready to write off this episode
is a bunch of pointless backstory you
drop this
vision soup for the soul bomb on me and
i realize how perfectly this episode
represents the process of therapy and
growth therapy rules
and so does this moment yes sir yeah
she's still here
hayward can see wanda on the screen so
why would he ask the apple leader at the
desk if she's still there
one moment i have to buzz you in i got
it thanks what is the process of buzzing
someone in that you couldn't have done
it in the time it took you to tell her
you needed to buzz her in
also still a dick moved by wanda here
either way they said you could head back
it's not going to take long
you can hold a spell i get that
superheroes would have to drive their
normal people buick like a boring person
from time to time but it feels so wrong
to me
it's like a werewolf holding a gun sort
of wrong jeez westview if you aren't
going to take care of that pool at least
drain it
you want mosquitoes because this is how
you get mosquitoes i would have given
all the sins back if we had one scene in
the past of vision being shown
properties by a realtor
for all the pretense of this episode
giving us explanations of how all this
started they really yada yada the hell
out of it at the end
this outburst of powers is pure chaos
and emotion for wanta to be able to keep
up what she's doing would require a lot
of control in planning
i don't see how this explains anything
for agatha that you probably didn't
already know
not giving your blade runner reference
is time to register wait where are we
now
did she create an actual home or create
a broadcast studio and if this is all in
her mind space then why would she be
imagining a studio with agatha in the
audience seating
why is camera this is chaos magic wanda
that makes you the scarlet [ __ ]
bored i see d plus took my note from
last week and removed the please stand
by screen
thank you now i know for sure there
won't be a mid-credits scene i always
appreciate the help disney
tried every type of power supply under
the sun
when all we needed was a little energy
directly from the source i love how
simple jay from drop dead diva makes
this sound
sure she zapped our drone so we now know
all the secrets to her energy and how to
capture it and transfer it to a vision
clone
voila if next week's episode isn't
called double vision
we riot
i'm seeing double here four krusty's
wanna hang out with us on a live stream
we don't care if you're on the toilet in
your mom's basement or in the broom
closet just put on some deodorant and
join us during sin week 20 21
march 22nd through 26th we'll release
three
extra sins videos and go live four times
to hang out with you all you have to do
is become a sin club member at
patreon.com
cinemasins do it now that way you're the
first to learn about our evil plans
and if you join today you have time to
watch over 70 exclusive videos and
podcasts
see you the week of the 22nd so what i
see here
is a baby witch obsessed with sitcoms
and years of therapy ahead of her
you stay in this dimension too long your
body's gonna disintegrate
and i for one can't wait to watch
the only way forward is back
that doesn't make sense you're social
slip in the juice
i watched the entire autopsy of this
creature pretty much
that the public has since come to know
as the alien autopsy
it's okay baby it's a beautiful
beautiful beautiful pair of twins
did you nurse children